okay okay no no I know it's great smell
but if you did not know now you know
your life is different now
I'm here with mamrie Hart hello me again
we wonder shoot videos today and maybe
it has a huge surprise for me on her
YouTube channel that oh no you just keep
telling me that you watch it was your
birthday I got you a gift and it's a
gift I'd like to give you on camera but
that is my expectation to live up to
when you go do you want to make
something for your YouTube channel I
think this might be a gift so please are
you kidding me I asked me for her
consent before this video if this is
okay to do we are going to be figuring
out what oh my god I couldn't care less
yeah everyone talks about it all the
time I know I'm like the one person on
earth who hasn't read Harry Potter I saw
a couple of the movies but only because
they came out on back on Thanksgiving
and like me and my family would go see a
movie at Thanksgiving so I'd be like yes
it means I have to talk to you for three
hours let's do this feel a little bad
because I feel like Hannah should be
here with me doing this but I also
hadn't pulled up oh my anytime that
Hannah and I have talked about what
Hogwarts house that we are in
mamrie has gotten a little perturbed for
good reason because anyone talking about
things you don't know is the NOI I am
NOT like a super Harry Potter fan
however I think that Ted is a wonderful
personality test oh no it's like a Myers
Brigg exactly wasn't Robert Pattinson
and extra on Harry Potter he was in
Harry Potter oh he's like a real
character I think so
I love when you pull up Roberts it goes
Muellers 'dear i've also debated doing
this video because it's like i don't
know enough about Harry Potter
to make fun Harry Potter quick
Cedric Diggory who is huge ah no he was
basically like the devon Sawa devon Sawa
like I will say up front - Hufflepuff I
sounds it's like something you'd want a
puddle yeah am I not well you don't like
touching like like a squishy like some
sort of like cream puff and just give
you some backstory I did not seek this
out on my own Lee Newton was the one
that first introduced me to the Sorting
Hat powder more quiz I feel like this is
my inside the mind of Jake Paul already
logged in oh okay
can't join us use they don't want to May
2014 I'm four years old so get your
passwords gonna be predict to agree you
guys sign into your actual account do I
need to create one I can't believe I'm
joining Pottermore yeah I'm never gonna
save your passcode you wanted to log on
to Pottermore and like pretend to be me
that's you know I'll give you that once
your email address has been verified
okay here we go please get rid of all
these other tabs porn hub porn biscuits
so the four houses are Gryffindor
Hufflepuff Ravenclaw and Slytherin
ravenclaw it doesn't get talked about
much are they boring I don't know and
you're all gonna scream in the comments
you sorted it and discover your house
here we begin be a forest or river what
does that mean you just enter forest or
river whatever I like rivers you like
interacting a week ago so select river
got whiplash you and two friends need to
cross a bridge guarded by a river troll
who insists on fighting one of you
before he will let you pass do you
attempt to confuse the troll into
letting all three of you pass without
fighting suggests drawing lots to decide
which of you will fight suggest that all
three of you should fight without
telling the troll or volunteer to fight
all three should fight which of the
following would you most hate people to
call you my actual name ordinary
ignorant cowardly or selfish
Oh which would you hate the most to be
called ordinary okay here we go
which of the following do you find most
difficult to deal with
five choices okay hunger cold hating
loneliness boredom or being ignored only
nice loneliness for boxes are placed
before you which would you try and open
for choices ready oh my god these are
[ __ ] I know this is different and
this Antiques Roadshow small
tortoiseshell box embellished with gold
inside which some small creature it
seems to be squeaking oh goodness the
gleaming jet black box with a silver
locking key mark with mysterious rune
that you know to be the mark of Merlin
the ornate golden casket standing on
clawed feet whose inscription warns that
both secret knowledge an unbearable
temptation lie with that sounds Raven
claw to make the small pewter box
unassuming and playing with a scratch
message upon it that reads I owe I open
only for the worthy
what the here's the thing is I would
normally say a little one with the loss
squeaking but what if it's a mouse
I'm gonna go to Merlin sounds magical
and Jeff likes the key marking I don't
know what a rune is though
what's a room you weren't attending
Hogwarts which pet would you choose to
take with you there's a ton here Eddy
tabby cat allergic Siamese cat allergic
ginger cat allergic black cat allergic
white cat allergic tawny owl screech owl
brown owl snowy owl mmm barn owl cutie
common toad natter Jack toe Dragon toad
Harlequin - oh Jesus
and three-toed tree toads marhaus people
what are you most looking forward to
learning at Hogwarts apparition and dis
separation being able to materialize and
dematerialize at will okay that's cool
Transfiguration turning one object into
another object flying on a broomstick
that's nerve-racking taxes and James's
little evil all about magical creatures
and how to befriend and care for them
secrets about the castle every area of
magic I can oh I'm going to say say then
I'll still get to learn about the
creatures and I can find a broomstick
it's just I don't want to go hi I know I
just want to like scooch and like go get
a bottle of mine like one the liquor
stores about close left or right right
right select no congratulations I'm
being sorted in Slytherin it's on muscle
burns most renowned members include
service name and Bellatrix Lestrange did
you think I was gonna be Slytherin two
hundred thousand here at the trace read
cunning and
resourceful shrewd determined what's
shrewd cunning is that- i don't think it
sounds like i would like do stuff to
other people over which i don't do my
are out here you go
our i've never heard anyone brag that
their Slytherin I'm like I'm a
Hufflepuff or I have a girlfriend or
whatever that slow birds are the ones
that sit back and wait to be asked my
even slytherins think that this is done
as you sit okay I cannot wait to text
Anna that you finally took the quiz and
that we have officially learned them I
just text her right now say I'm a
Slytherin oh you can also click to
download the image pack who tell your
friends that you're a processor I'm
totally good I mean your question is
finally been answered memory is in fact
a Slytherin and how proud are we of her
for taking this test it's incredible let
us know in the comments down below what
you guys are like I said I'm a
Hufflepuff um other than that subscribe
always go watch our video on my channel
where I give grace her birthday gift yes
link is in the description below if you
haven't already watched her any other
than that I don't know yeah okay you
guys 30 seconds later Hannah responded
she hath locked what did you take
Pottermore that's the only legit quiz I
did we did and I'm Slytherin oh my god
she's so stuck she's never shown about
this she's gonna be so bummed she wasn't
here for it she was here twice over dad
looks like aren't there like Malfoy
twins
that's literally mouth white and Hannah
were here for the day